la parole est à notre collègue sophie
primas pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social madame la ministre le 9
septembre 2012 président de la
république annonçait qu'il allait
inverser la courbe du chômage d'ici un
an et pierre moscovici à la même époque
déclarait la version est possible elle
va arriver à la fin de l'année j'en ai
la conviction une conviction disait-il
informé à la fin de l'année 2013 le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi avait
augmenté de 6 et demi pour cent fin mars
2014 notre pays dépassait les 5 millions
de chômeurs trois ans après l'élection
du président de la république en 2015
la france a atteint le chiffre
historique d'un chômage à 5 7 millions
de demandeurs d'emploi les derniers
chiffres publiés du chômage ceux
d'octobre ont montré un bond sans
précédent
quarante deux mille chômeurs de plus en
un seul mois
c'est très mauvais résultats
interviennent alors que l'euro est
faible alors même que le cours du
pétrole est également et que le taux
d'intérêt sont très bas
tous les pays européens profitent de
cette situation pour réformer et pour
créer des emplois
l'allemagne la grande-bretagne qui est
quasiment au grand temps au plein emploi
l'italie dirigé par un gouvernement de
gauche l'espagne et même la grèce tous
sauf la france
madame la ministre combien faudra-t-il
de chômeurs de plus pour que le
gouvernement prenne enfin conscience que
les politiques qu'ils mènent sont plus
destructrice que créatrice d'emplois
dans un pays qui pourtant a tant
d'atouts tant de créativité tant de
chefs d'entreprise audacieux et qu'il
faut libérer le président de la
république a dit hier au conseil des
ministres que l'important était de
définir le cap
madame la ministre quel est ce cap pour
vous répondre
la parole est au ministre du travail de
l'emploi la formation professionnelle
gaver la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice sophie primas tout
d'abord ce cap
c'est bien sûr que les chômeurs
actuellement dans une situation en effet
de parfois de détresse puisse retrouver
le chemin de l'emploi
pour faire baisser durablement le
chômage il faut deux préalables
le premier c'est la croissance cette
croissance est à 1,1 pour cent au delà
nos prévisions et elle n'est pas
suffisante justement pour compenser les
entrées tous les ans sur le marché du
travail
une comparaison par rapport à
l'allemagne vous avez tous les ans en
france 700 milles départ en retraite en
moyenne et vous avez 850000 entrée sur
le marché du travail en allemagne c'est
700 milles départ en retraite et 660
mille entrées sur le marché du travail
donc comparons ce qui est comparable
le deuxième préalable c'est que
l'économie crée de l'emploi est en effet
après plusieurs années de destructions
d'emplois depuis un an nous avons très
37 mille 600 créations nettes d'emplois
ce n'est pas suffisant bien évidemment
ce n'est pas suffisant vu la situation
de chômage est ce que nous constatons
c'est pour ça que nous avons des
chiffres avec des variations extrêmement
forte d'un mois à un autre c'est que les
emplois qui sont créés sont
malheureusement des emplois précaires en
intérim ou en cdd et nous avons des
secteurs qui fonctionne bien je pense
notamment au tertiaire qui créent de
l'emploi
mais nous avons d'autres secteurs
l'industrie le bâtiment
justement où ils ne sont pas suffisants
et où il ya des emplois qui sont encore
détruits
qu'est ce que l'on fait par rapport à
cette situation concrètement nous
n'attendons pas tous les mois les
chiffres du chômage dans notre bureau
qu'est ce que nous faisons lorsque le
gouvernement comme vendredi dernier met
en place la mesure sur les particuliers
employeurs qui ce qui est un domaine
créateurs d'emplois cela permet
justement d'en créer de nombreux lorsque
nous mettons en place le prêt à taux
zéro en direction du bâtiment sa vie
justement à créer l'ambiance leur
conclave loupé également les formations
prioritaire sur les emplois non pourvus
bien évidemment il faut continuer à
aller plus vite et plus loin
madame prime à madame la ministre les
bras m'en tombent
25 % de chômage chez les jeunes des
contrats d'apprentissage en baisse
constante huit cent mille chômeurs de
longue durée
je crois que vous êtes sourd à ce qui
s'est produit dimanche dernier dans les
urnes
je me bats pour l'emploi c'est une
volonté une stratégie une cohérence 10 m
martial le président de la république
cela sonne aujourd'hui comme un terrible
aveu d'échec